where is it where where is it
i'm going to the masjid in time to pray
it's a beautiful day
where is the masjid where is the masjid
where's the masjid
where is the save iman norway masjid i
can't see it where is it
relax relax alhamdulillah we've
purchased this huge
2700 square meters building with this
huge
a half thousand square meters of land
and insha'allah with your help we are
going to convert this huge property into
the most epic islamic center in the
whole country of norway and this is not
one of those one-off ajit projects where
you give your sadaka and you get the
reward for that one specific deed that
you donated towards now this is a sadaqa
area that will keep on giving you
rewards for as long as this masjid
stands which can be hundreds of years in
sha allah you will insha allah be
receiving the ajir from all of the
prayers being established in this masjid
the kids learning about their deen all
of the hafad who come out of this center
and all other insha allah click the
button to donate whatever you can
[Music]
you